what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
the 24th of march let me ask you
something
when you go to the bathroom you always
close the door behind you right
you don't want people looking on you
you're in there [__] [__]
looking around smelling you're confused
so why would you let people see what you
do online
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door
do you know that the creepy internet
providers actually spy on what you do
every single website you visit and then
they turn around
and sell your info to ad companies
listen to me it's like buying a [__]
plane ticket you ever buy
look for a plane ticket like i'm
thinking i'm gonna go to nashville in
two weeks let me see how much it is
you [__] press the stuff down an hour
later every time you open up the
computer
there's plane deals to nashville from
the delta
american united qantas that's why
they know what the [__] you're doing
expressvpn puts a stop to this madness
it creates a secure tunnel between you
and the internet
no one can see what you're up to you
know what i'm saying
it's between you and the big man
upstairs that's it
it works on all devices and on wi-fi
and it covers everyone in your home plus
it's easy to use it's closing the
[__] bathroom door
just push one button and you're
protected that's why
expressvpn is rated number one so if
you're like me
and you believe your online activity is
your business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
joey that's expressvpn.com
joey plus what i'm gonna do for you is
i'm gonna get you an extra three months
three months for free support the joint
and protect your privacy
at expressvpn.com
the joint is also brought to you by on
it the best
as far as alpha brain is concerned the
[__] i wouldn't be here
i was all [__] mumbling and
stuttering in the beginning of this
[__] podcast three months ago
and now i'm tip top magoo not really but
i'm faking the funk you know what i'm
saying
alpha brain is where it's at you try it
if you don't like it they give you your
money back a hundred percent and they
get
you get to keep the product also i'm a
big shroom tech guy
i'm a big protein bar guy if you don't
like pills they have new mood now and
powder they have
alpha brain and powder i mean listen i
can't get you anything on kettlebells
and the
club bats but as far as supplements i'll
get you ten percent off
go to honor.com right now and preston
church
and get 10 off on the best nootropics
out there alpha brain they
started the [__] game everybody else
went after
started their [__] nootropic thing at
the alpha brain
go with alpha brain i know that you're
down your moods are down
you want to get back to thinking go to
honor.com it all starts with that go to
honor.com
look at the fine line of supplements
whether it's new mood
new mood powder alpha brain the [__]
melatonin spray is tremendous
and it works against covet so it's up to
you go to honor.com right now and press
in church
and get ten percent off your order
delivered right to your house
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen to me
enough is enough if your team wins this
weekend
you win 100 hours it's that simple pick
any college basketball team
that's still in the running for your
shot at getting 100
and all it takes is about a dollar so
you're turning one dollar
into a hundred dollars that's a hundred
to one odds
these are the kind of odds you see once
in a [__] lifetime that's why i'm
saying
draftking sportsbook is going [__]
nuts you also have ufc 260 this week
stipe against ungayo whatever his
[__] name is they're going to be
punching themselves until they both
don't know
who the [__] is who they're going to ask
who the [__] are you i don't know
[__] albums and silver
i don't know but anyway draftkings is
safe secure
and reliable you withdraw your money
when you want it's your [__] money
it's your money who the [__] is the [__]
with you listen download the draftking
sportsbook app now
and use promo code joey and sign up to
turn a dollar
into 100 and they're also going to do
the same thing with the ufc
they're going to have a certain certain
fights that are you better dollar
and you win 100 hours come on guys
download the drop
top rated draftking sportsbook app and
use promo code joey to turn one dollar
into a hundred for a limited time only
at draftking sportsbook
and here's the fine print you got to be
21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details if you got a
gamer palm listen you got to get it
under control
uh this is not for you if you have a
camera bomb but if you know how to
gamble
and you know [__] not over your head
and do the right thing and you just want
to have some [__] fun
listen i lost the other day and i had
fun because i just watched the game and
i was giving points and i didn't [__]
cover
it's fun they got boost they got parlays
you're not into sports
they got an online casino that'll make
your [__] wake flip
go right now to draftkings.com and
download the draftking sportsbook app
pre
use promo code joey and get the [__]
deal of a lifetime
i love you guys let's get this [__]
party started right now
old school candles [__] lit bam
hey how you doing come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 24th i got my happy
blue shirt on because
what else are you gonna [__] wear you
gotta be happy you know what i'm saying
blue makes me feel better makes you feel
better i'm not coming in with a black
shirt the whole [__] thing especially
when i wake up the [__] weird
listen we're living in a world that you
never know what you're going to wake up
to anymore
i woke up this morning i got my call for
you know i kissed my daughter i talked
to her for a few minutes
and you go downstairs and what the [__]
you open up the computer
and i gotta read the [__] what's that
chick's name from three's company
uh susan susan whatever is
73 and she's having [__]
sex [__] four times a day i
i need to know that i need to know that
that i'm happy for you whatever your
[__] name is what's her name
suzanne summers suzanne summers is
having sex three times a day by
lunchtime first of all
listen do you i'm like you i'm 58 and i
have a hard time looking at my dick
because i'm getting old i can't imagine
what a 70 year old [__] smells and
smells and tastes like at this point in
the game
suzanne you're good looking but you're
[__] 74 step back
i mean this is what you got to wake up
to a 74 year old telling you she's
having [__] sex
you know that's great what's your [__]
smell like panty liners and [__] piss
and whatever
are you [__] crazy suzanne summers i
woke up and i thought about that image
on the computer i'm like what the [__]
is going on with the world
every [__] day is something crazy
suzanne summers
what else [__] happened something
else happened that [__] i sat there
and i couldn't believe it oh
oh krispy kreme is giving you a [__]
donut if you get the vaccine
whoa [__] i'm running down there now
to eat one of those old donuts they
throw away to the homeless people at
night
that's what you're gonna get can you
imagine like what [__] incentive is
that that krispy kreme is gonna give you
a [__] donut
you wanted to send it to me give me a
[__] lobster tail how about a ball
lick
if you get the code the test they have
like [__] suzanne summers and a 74
year old [__]
giving you a [__] ball lick or
something like this what the [__] is
going on
every time you open up the computer it's
something [__] different in the
morning you're like
did i just read what i just [__] read
am i just [__] going crazy or is it
black sabbath has a song am i going
insane tell me people am i going insane
i gotta tell you something that's how i
feel sometimes by the [__] i'm reading
suzanne [__] sums unfucking
believable i have sex three times by
lunchtime
good for you good for you suzanne 74
years old
your [__] saggy titties and your
saggy [__] [__]
your [__] hangs down low and [__] it's a
[__] nightmare i
i just who would have [__] say that
in this time like that's gonna make my
mental health
better i'm happy for you suzanne simms
but now to get to the [__] thick and
the heavy man
monday blew my [__] mind
i was having a great day i was busy as
[__]
and i got bad news from two [__]
fronts
the first front i got bad news from is
my daughter started softball it was
[__] tremendous
she started her first [__] practice
monday night
guys you don't know what it's like when
your life comes full circle and some
days you'll all be in my position when
you're older
and you get to look at back at what
you've done and what you haven't done
and
how your life is going and uh it's just
great that that
god gave me a second chance and we
picked up another girl from a team
and we drove her and they broke them
into three [__] uh
you know three little [__] areas and
some girls batted some girls [__] ran
bases some girls got you know learning
how to field
some girls learn how to it was just
tremendous but in the middle of this
the first call i got was that there was
a shooting
in boulder you know i i i was so
enthralled in the moment the sunshine
my daughter talking to other parents
that when my friend called me
he was like you know it was george my
brother he was like it was
the the king supers that we used to go
to and i'm like really and i didn't like
i said guys i would show them the moment
that i didn't think about what was going
on afterwards my daughter
we uh dropped the girl off nicole and
me and my daughter went we got some i
got a vegetarian burrito it doesn't
really matter whatever we came home and
then
uh last night i got a chance you know
just
for some [__] reason against my
best interest i turned on that [__]
cnn
and i was watching what was going on and
i was heartbroken i was just [__]
heartbroken i told you guys
eight months ago that covert wasn't the
only problem we have right now
the problem that we have right now in
this country is mental health
mental health has gone to [__] how do i
how do we know how do i know this
because i suffered through it i went
through a [__] mental mental
breakdown
march april may if you watch
the first five episodes of this podcast
i was stuttering still i i wasn't myself
this is
hey man it just happens this isolation
changing careers just puts a strain on
people
you know relationships people you know
people are really getting to think this
gives you a time to think so i knew
things were going to happen you know
this thing up in [__] minneapolis is
a shame the covert the amount of people
dying
you know this country is just going
through a period of
we're unsettled still you know we've
been locked in a cage for a year
you know some people have no
unemployment some people
just it's just everybody has a different
way of handling things
for me it was [__] going to [__]
pills and [__] edibles and smoking
pot all day
and i knew that wasn't the [__]
answer i had to deal with what was in
front of me
but this boulder thing last night really
[__] made me [__] think because
that supermarket
was a special place to me as as dumb
as the sound and you know guys i tell
you
how i feel from the bottom of my heart
on every [__] episode
last night when i was looking at first
of all that king supers was just
a a supermarket and then if you went
past down there was a little tiny strip
mall
and there was a bar they had a couple
things i really don't remember i knew
they had a bar because they had a dinner
special
and every night they had like a early
dinner like five to seven
you get like for nine dollars you got
and they made a tremendous trout
almondine
and i would go there twice or three
times a week
you know that king supers i lived
in that area from
september of 87
to april of 88 that is where i lived
south boulder when i kidnapped
vela i lived across the street from that
supermarket
that's the supermarket i still remember
all the [__] that happened in that
supermarket i used to
you know i used to shop there so i would
shop every
kind of every other day let's say i
would go for something to eat fresh
and i remember one sunday hungover
i you know crossed the street i didn't
go to the yellow like to the corner
in the middle i just cut across the
street jaywalking what they call it
and while i was jaywalking i heard a
tire hit something
and it hit a wallet that was on the
floor and i remember like hitting the
corner and going
somebody threw a wall out of a car let
me go see what's in there and i
just out of curiosity i went over picked
up the wallet they took the credit cards
they cleaned out everything but there
was a little secret compartment
and i opened it up and there was 200
bills i was never so happy in my [__]
life that's one of my pleasant [__]
memories about that
but that king supers used to put their
bags of dog
food outside and i had a dog then
hercules
and i would just go shopping
and then on the way out i would just
pick up a bag of dog food and walk home
i wouldn't even pay for it i mean
i'm so [__] ashamed to tell you these
stories this has nothing to do with
what happened i'm just telling you my
connection to this place they had a
seafood department in there
and the guy was from new orleans the
smoothest coolest
black dude you've ever met in your life
he loved me and george
and he would make his skewers he would
make swordfish and mahi mahi and shrimp
and peppers and
more shrimp and he would put it in
skewers and marinate it
in this [__] new orleans [__] [__]
and we would go in there every day get
swordfish steaks
just kebabs and just walk out of the
store
like i would go when are they gonna find
out that we're not
we're not paying for this [__]
seafood me and george were eating like
[__] kings
that's the apartment that i had the
house i had
where [__] the cops came to get me
that's where i lived when the mailman
sprayed my [__] dog
and i pushed him and the feds came to my
house dawg i got memories from that
[__] neighborhood so
you gotta understand that that hit me
[__] just
last night i was like all this [__] kept
flashing up i i
just i i called a friend of mine manny
tomino who was my friend in boulder who
lives in belmont new jersey i'm gonna
go visit him pretty soon and we talked
about boulder and he was like which one
what king supers was it because we lived
when i lived with manny that's why i
moved april of 88 before i got sentenced
he was my brother man he still is
he lived on the main boulder he lived in
north boulder manny
and there was a king supers on arapahoe
boulevard arapaho road
and that was my king supers that's why i
used to go and get the
gouda cheese with the fresh orange sweet
juice at night after i'd do comedy
and i would drive to arapahoe and 55th
and there was an acura dealer there
honda dealer
and i would just sit in my beat up
[__] jalopy
dreaming about the day that someday i
could afford a [__] acura
30 something years old and i had a beat
up [__] car piece of [__]
but i told manny this i go i remember
all those king supers but the one in
table mesa
that won where the shooting was let me
tell you what my
biggest memory was from that that's
where i found out
i was going to [__] prison i would
shop there like i said
every other day i would go over there
whatever you know
hamburgers [__] like that but one day i
actually went in there
and on my kidnapping that's where i
lived when i kidnapped bella
that's where i live when i got out and
that's where i lived when i started
getting my
life together a little bit before i went
to prison
up to this point like i got out in
december and up to that point i was like
i'm gonna beat this case
it had to be like april of 88 and i
walked into this king supers
and i was just walking around the hall
in
isles looking for whatever the [__] it
is i was looking for
and i looked up and i saw the district
attorney in my case
i had already been writing letters you
guys know i'm a letter writer
i started writing him letters as soon as
i got out of the [__]
county you know i got his [__]
address and i started writing them
letters about what happened
and uh i i wasn't saying how sorry i was
i wasn't
uh that was my big problem i was just
writing what was me letters you know
[__] typical junky [__]
that that's who i was then you know it
wasn't my fault uh
it was a bad day but nowhere would i cop
to it
you know and i'll never forget that i
said this is my chance to go
[__] talk to this guy you know face
to face with no attorneys
or nothing like this and between you me
guys he was a good guy he
he i mean you you guys want me to say he
was a scumbag
he was going to throw me in prison he
was doing his job
he was a good guy and i approached him
like a man
and i said i forget what his name is now
i said
excuse me can i have a word with you and
he goes
you know because of our situations we
can't really talk
but i'll give you two minutes
and i said to him you know listen
i i i did what i did you know i just
played the same broken joey diaz record
for him
you know what i was doing in those days
it was always everybody else's fault it
was the world's fault
it was that my mom died it was this it
was that was just [__] excuses that i
give myself
that we all give ourselves uh after
prison i stopped doing that excuse and i
cop to whatever the [__] i do if you do
it you did it and cop them who gives a
[__]
who are they to judge you anyway you
know but i was dumb
at the time i was 25 [__] years old
it was 1988
and i went up to him and i went up with
my [__] thing they looked at me and
he goes listen man
i appreciate what you're doing i
appreciate that you're trying to get
into college i appreciate that you got
your ged
because i appreciate that you're doing
these things but you also have to
consider that you did a crime
and it was a crime that there could have
been a potential
for violence a bullet could have gone
off a neighbor could have been
shot something it could have been a
potential for violence
you have to face the [__] music
nothing has ever cut my stomach like
those words when he said it to me
this was way before comedy this was way
before people were calling me out
you know i lived a life where nobody
would call me out because i was [__]
nuts
i was [__] nuts you know they didn't
know what i was gonna do to him
or how i was gonna react but this guy
said [__] to me that
he wasn't lying he goes listen man i
looked over your folder
i looked over the investigative reports
and i looked over who the [__] you've
been for the last
whatever years he goes
you've been chuckling and jiving he goes
that's your gift and i appreciate it
that you have that
and i appreciate it that you're doing
all these things but
you've been chucking and driving it's
time for you to pay the [__] piper
and i'm sorry to have to be the person
to do that i'm really sorry and i
apologize to you
and in time it'll make you a better
person i looked at him like
how is jail gonna make me a better
person when i have options of
actually going to college i didn't
understand where he was coming from
i needed to [__] change he read me
that
and i remember we were about to throw
like the the frozen isle food you know
with the [__] that you picked
like to have my corn dogs and frozen egg
rolls and [__] like that
there's no windows i i still remember
that he was looking through [__]
he was telling me this making eye
contact but when he told me that chuck
and jive would be lying
like i nearly [__] died because he
wasn't lying
he told me the [__] truth he was like
listen man
it's time for you to [__] pay the
piper you've been [__] chucking and
jiving moving along all your life
he goes i read the reports out of san
francisco you had police contact up
there
you had police contact in new jersey had
police contact in new york
and i've read all these [__] files
and uh
it's time for you to pay for some of
your things i shook his hand
i said thank you for your time he shook
my hand
he told me thank you for understanding
and i walked out of there
i think george came to me two weeks
later and said he wanted to move back to
new york that he had gotten opportunity
in framing
and that gave me time to think about
what that man said to me but that's
why this thing in boulder is just
mind-boggling to me it it is something
that
it's going to continue to happen now i
think there was another
this is the first time in american
history there was two mass shootings
in one week you know the other one i
think was asian
it was more of asians in florida i don't
know what happened
like i said i'm not up on the news
anymore because of how down it brought
me
you know i tried to avoid yahoo with the
[__] plague
you know i tried to avoid facebook and
the twitter page you know i post
and i get the [__] out of there you know
like i said this morning i seen the
suzanne summers thing
and at least broke the you know i
laughed i giggled i giggled at the
[__] uh
you know whatever but then there's the
reality
of things you know numbers are going
back up
you know whatever's going on in south
beach with people jumping up and down i
mean look
what do you expect what do [__]
people expect
you've had us in a cage for a year
you've
[__] [__] with us about
unemployment you [__] us about race
you [__] us i mean you know telling us
numbers that just don't make sense
telling us things that don't make
[__] sense i'm sitting here the other
night with my [__] wife
and she's watching new jersey 12 for the
[__] weather
and i swear to god we tried to catch it
like because it starts every half hour
on the hour
so you could try to catch the end but
for some reason we let it run into the
10 o'clock [__] hour we were doing
something i was at my desk
and we were downstairs in the basement
and the guy goes
[__] there's a new variant in
brooklyn uh
you know it's all around brooklyn but
we're opening up restaurants 75 percent
in new york so
yeah people are walking around like what
do i believe
and what don't i believe mental health
guys
is that an all-time [__] high
all-time [__] high we could turn our
backs on it
and we can make believe you know half of
you instead of watching this [__]
podcast
or listen to the podcast i feel
have are feeling things that you've
never felt before
i i am i am i can't if you listen if you
want me to sit here
and tell you [__] that my world is
[__]
tremendous i'll lie to you and tell you
that my wife is healthy
i'm healthy my daughter's healthy
they're back in school i love what i'm
doing down here
but i got to be honest with you the days
are long
uh your mind seems to go into different
places because the day is so long
and you're not doing what you used used
to be doing and living i mean
my life is a little better than what it
was than when i got here
you could see it in my face i'm happier
i'm healthier you know everything
around that is working but for most
americans
it's not a [__] party right now it's
not a [__] party
we're learning how to zoom we're
learning how to work at home
we're learning how to deal with our kids
not being in school we're learning how
to
we're learning so many [__] different
things that it's over [__] whelming
right now
you know the the well what vaccine do i
think i mean we're all trying to do the
right thing
we're all trying to do the right thing
we're all trying to [__] to decide
what vaccine to think
but every two days you know that's tough
let's take it
it's going to give you blood clots this
one is giving you this this one is
giving you that why can't we just focus
on one [__] thing
but every day is a [__] different so
americans yes
we are having a hard time australia
isn't locked down
you know the uk is having their [__]
problems the world is in a weird [__]
spot
but never in 2000
[__] listen there's things that have
blown my mind completely
i never ever ever thought i would ever
get in the movie
boy was i wrong i never ever ever
thought i was gonna get married again
boy was i wrong i never ever wanted
another child of the pain that comes
with
losing a child like i did you know i
never thought that would happen
but never in my [__] life
did i think that somebody would go into
a supermarket
in boulder the land of sandals people
have birkenstocks they don't even want
to [__] run
if there's a shooter never in my life
would i think that somebody would take
10 lives in boulder on a monday
[__] afternoon and march never never
i saw one guy this is when i turned off
the tv last night
and started practicing the guitar they
interviewed one guy he was on a street
corner and he goes
he was crying he was a 30 year old man
crying saying
that he thought he was in the safest
place in the world that he never thought
he would lose his life over getting a
[__] soda
i mean and this is the same way i feel
listen
crime went up 61 percent now you're
going to hear about shootings there
you know minneapolis is just waiting to
blow
uh you know st louis is a racial hotbed
right now
you know miami i mean we have all these
spots
i expect that you know texas is the land
of guns i love texas
i i you know it's the land of guns
colorado's the land of guns they haven't
make my day law
which i love myself i live by until this
day
if i see your leg come through my window
i just sit there with a gun
and aim up and shoot at you you know i
mean i love all these laws and stuff
like that but
i don't like people taking 10 [__]
lives
of people were just shopping there were
people getting covered test
people online getting a [__] covet
test waiting to get a [__] cope with
this so
i hated to come at this gloom with you
but it's there i have to address this
elephant in the room and tell you how i
feel about it
because it did hit me [__] hard you
know listen man
when that [__] kid got shot the lady
got kid
i don't know him i have no i i don't
know him i've never met him
i've never met lady gaga i've never met
lady gaga's dogs you know
it's not like i know these people but
dog i didn't feel good that week
why i walked those streets i used to
walk those streets in boulder
with josh wolf and ralphie and doug
stanhope and mitch
sure it's gonna affect me that could
that could have been any one of us
i mean god for no none of us lived there
no more ralphies dead mitch is dead
doug is in [__] uh you know arizona
i'm here
it doesn't matter it has to affect me in
a certain way i lived there i walked
those streets those were my neighbors
you know that was my 7-eleven that was
my liquor store that was my gym there
that was where
justin fortune's gym was with naca foley
and all my friends there
sure i'm going to react a certain way
but this you know this in la they're
shooting people for a [__] watch in
beverly hills i understand
but boulder the home of naropa institute
half the people there are buddhists half
the people there
are [__] and i hate to say this
because they just had a tragedy but
they're like fake hippies but it's a
land of love
it's like it really is that that trust
fund hippies
they got beards and and things and they
don't cut their fingernails and they
they wear dirty clothes but then that
you see them hide their audi
they're 80 thousand dollar audi you're
like how the [__] are you a hippie
and they hate corporate america and they
hate all this [__] they're just rich
kids that are confused
but still not confused enough to shoot
10 people at a [__] supermarket they
just
you know little [__] hippie kids man
it just uh
sucks the [__] energy out of me
i mean i i even thought about calling my
ex-wife and checking in
just because and i know that they don't
live in south boulder they're not even
close to it but
brother this this is no bueno for a guy
like me this
is uh like i said i called my friend my
man mike roebuck
i called manny and the last guy called
after the guitar lessons was george
george was working
and we spoke last night about it like
how
what the [__] is going on you know but
hey
it's life today it's why i come on here
once a week to break up them
twice a week to break up the [__]
monotony and just talk to you about
life and the stupid things we [__]
encounter you know
but this is what's going on today guys
and i hope that if you're feeling
if you're feeling weird or in any way
reach out
reach out to somebody i'm sick of
telling you people this
you don't have to feel this way you
don't deserve to feel this way
there's you know you have friends i
don't care if you have to
you know now you i love to tell you your
friends you go to the supermarket
but you can't even do that anymore i
mean you don't know what is going to pop
off
what area is going to pop off and that's
what's got me all [__] up you know
like i said i hate to bring this up
during the podcast today and whatnot
especially after the great time we have
with greg fitzsimmons
i'm happy you people enjoyed that you
could actually see
you know i watched 10 or 15 minutes of
that podcast
and uh i'm happy you're enjoying these
things
and whatnot and they help you but i'm
also looking at me and these things
every day you know mike post an old clip
from the church
and he posts a clip from whatever and i
look at both clips
and i see the change i don't i i i'm not
talking about the losing the weight
i'm not talking about the bags are on my
eyes i'm not talking about my hair
getting grayer
i'm not talking about that stuff i can
actually see
the interchange that i the weight that
fell off my [__] shoulders
i could feel all that
i was in a toxic environment and i
didn't [__] even know it
and i wasn't in a like a like it wasn't
a toxic environment in my marriage
it was the toxic environment and my
friends it wasn't a toxic environment
and what i was doing it was just a whole
big picture of comedy
of what was going on and the [__]
deals that were getting cut
and what comics were worried about and
what i was worried about and what i
i should have been doing in the first
place you know when i moved
i i didn't know i was gonna have i
didn't know i was going i was in it this
deep
i didn't find out till i landed here how
bad my head was in the shape i was in
emotionally
and mentally and uh this has just worked
out for me 150 [__] percent you know
and
i'm here to add levity to your lives you
know
i try to be funny on some episodes some
episodes i come here and we just talk
you know that's all we could do and
maybe just this hour will be
something that you've been thinking
about that i touch on and yes
you know it's uh
it's just a scary time for us now i
gotta tell you about the second
batch of bad news i got yesterday
so i went off the [__] pain pills i
threw away the [__]
oxycodones they hit me with
vikings i didn't touch the vikings for
two days
i started getting a little pain on that
wednesday
and then i took like vikings for two
days and that was it
i fought off the pain i gotta tell you
something guys last week
for some reason like one of the days
mike was here
i had unusual pain did i
take a painful no i took some of the
leaves and
i rub cbd lying on my leg and [__]
uh you know i put ice on my leg
i got a [__] you know the other thing
i've been using
towards this is a company that nate uh
nate ellenberger is part of like a vault
dodge
he sent me the gun two years ago when he
did the podcast
he sent me a knee brace that heats up
and vibrates
you know i've been doing that for the
pain i did everything i could
but i knew that something wasn't right
with my knee
when i would take a shower i take two
showers a day when i would take a shower
i dry off cause [__] the other day i
took off my knee braces and i smelled
them
i didn't know my knees stunk that
[__] bad because it's so [__] dry
here
that the skin my skin comes off when i
pull
so if i'm going to do like a something
like if i'm going to have like a long
day of walking around
i actually put knee braces on my right
leg and my left leg i got the advice
from tom segura thank god and the doctor
told me
i had to do the same so whenever i take
off my [__]
knee braces i bought two pair i don't
know i smell them
just you know i i don't know the same
way i smell my underwear i don't [__]
know you know
you got to smell your odors to know that
you're [__] disgusting
animal so i smell my [__] knee brace
and they smell bad so
what i do is i rub cream i rub uh
i get like a healthy cream and i rub it
on and then i have cbd line i rub about
1 000 milligrams
on both knees and i let it air dry
before i put my underwear and whatnot so
whenever i rub last week when i was
rubbing my knee
i saw that there was a little bruising
mike you're gonna [__] when i tell you i
thought there was a little bruising
so what did i do last week i called the
doctor last week because when i wake up
in the morning
i feel that my leg is in like a little
baby l
like it just feels a little crooked when
i wake up in the morning it's tight
when i get up i walk around a little bit
i make my coffee and then i come down
and i throw ice on it
and my first 15 minutes where i clear my
head up i just open the back door i look
out if it's sunny out
i go outside and i put the ice on my leg
and i just clear out my mind
to you know to see what i'm going to do
for the day and then once the 20 minutes
of the ice i get my notebook and i
journal
and i [__] go into it
so i called the [__] the one day it
was just getting worse in the mornings
i'm like what the [__] is this that my
leg
i mean it straightens out remember i
told you last week i went to pt
they [__] straightened them they
twisted they found no problems with it
but there was a little pain and when i
came home again no pain pills
i leave and [__] did [__]
so i asked my doctor last week two days
in a row for a drug that i cannot
pronounce
corticasim it's a muscle relaxer it's
like uh
if anybody knows the name of it correct
me like i said i'm not a pharmacist
i'm not here to tell you the correct
names of [__] it's a pill they gave me
in the beginning in the hospital and i
asked him and he goes
make sure you take this along with the
pain medication it's not a pain
medication you're not going to get high
but it's like a muscle relaxer it'll
loosen up your area and blah blah blah
so i kept calling them last week because
i ran out of it and i thought that's
what it was so i called him i called him
i called him nothing this [__]
doesn't send me in the prescription
he sends me an appointment he goes come
back and see me monday
so i go to the [__] doctor monday
they do all these x-rays
they clear me but then the assistant
knocked on the [__] door
and she comes in she goes i want you to
look at something
does your leg hurt here here and they
started poking on my leg and
he poked somewhere and i'm like ah and
he goes okay they looked at the x-rays
and then they said you might have tore
something
can we do another x-ray to see so i went
back in the [__] room
and they [__] did another x-ray from
a different angle and the guy goes
listen
this is what happened your knee is fine
your knee is 100
knock on wood you did all the right
things but somewhere along the line
you ripped like a small tendon in there
that contributes to that pain
to that leg being [__]
uh whatever so tomorrow morning
at six a.m it's just a two-hour
procedure
it's like putting a cam up your ass that
same colonoscopy
if they use that same anesthesia it's
not going to be
i'll listen i'll be home by [__] 10
11 o'clock it's just a little slit
just they're gonna zip it up
and they're gonna send me home i don't
need any opiates afterward
but i won't be able to [__] stand for
more than like
10 minutes 15 minutes at a time for
maybe two or three weeks that's what's
been hurting me on the side
so because of that i'm pushing the uncle
vinnie shows
i am [__] sorry about this this is
out of my control
last week they were closed because
somebody went in there with [__]
covert and they were scared so vinnie
wanted
dino the owner who's a great guy wanted
to protect everybody so
we closed it last week this week we got
more bad news my [__] knee
so i'll be out of commission for a few
weeks we're still going to be doing the
podcast
but it's just some time it's the t
something you know years ago i don't
know if you guys know of a guy named
mark d'onofrio
mark ganafio was a great football player
he's a little he's 10 years younger than
me
but i grew up with his older brother
mark was a great football player got
drafted by green bay
started as a linebacker got a signing
bonus big deal the whole [__] thing
and he ripped not your groin muscle
but a certain muscle in his groin area
this is the [__] weirdest thing
this is what it made me think of he
ripped this muscle
that only water skiers could rip
only people who water ski rip this
muscle it's like a little tiny [__]
muscle
that no it's like the [__] chances of
you ripping this muscle
are like a thousand the [__] one mark
danafio ripped the [__] muscle
a year off it was that much of that
you had to go deep in there mend it and
then it was he had to learn how to walk
again the whole [__] thing
and guess what happened he went to
[__] play the next season
and he ripped the exact same muscle on
the other [__] side people have
deficiencies who the [__] knows
you know i'm not a muscle terror uh i
tore my
hamstring last year when i slipped at
the comedy store
and now this [__] thing so what we're
gonna do is this
we're gonna push back the shows for a
few weeks
see how the leg feels and
uh i'm also going to get vaccinated in
the meantime
yes i'm probably going to take a johnson
johnson because i'm a [__]
but you got to give me credit but at
least i'm trying
and then we will go out 100 i i think
i'll feel a little better
and going back to vinnie's doing a
little uh
what do you call that what i was doing
before every wednesday just
working out just every [__] week just
working out i think it's time
and that's it i'll just keep it simple
but i'm very sorry if you had plans this
week
and next week and if you had plans last
week it's [__] colvin
and you know this is why i tell people
i'm living my life day to [__] day
i don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow you know i'm out of [__]
fortune balls whatever the [__] they're
called what what's your cookie
not fortune cookie magic 8 balls no just
the regular [__]
balls that you know tell you the future
i'm out of them and i don't know nobody
who's working on this either so
first of all it's a day-to-day thing
this life that's why when people call me
now like hey
can you bro it's a day-to-day [__]
thing who the [__]
knows you know i call you to set
something up in there
i've had so many [__] things fall
apart lately
you know because of stupid things not
just and i don't get mad at them
guys you cannot get mad at people for
getting covered
you can't get mad at a school because a
student
you know i stopped getting mad let's get
through this
let now there's a variant let's get
through the [__] variant and we can
move forward like [__] normal people
but until this happens i i don't know
what to tell you you know i see all
these schedules
i see all these people with big plans
[__] you know arenas and
opening back up tours are getting
announced
but you're telling me on one hand all
this shit's happening but on the other
hand you're telling me we're only going
to be at 50
in these [__] big arenas this summer
so i don't know if these bands are going
to fly out i know for a fact
somebody told me that that def leppard
molly root thing is on
oh really yeah it's on in florida april
i i
i this is what i heard i do not know
do not quote me i'm not a [__]
concert promoter
i'm just letting you know that nobody
knows nothing nobody knows nothing
it's a day-to-day [__] world right
now this is what you gotta live with
um i'm sorry if you had plans you know i
had plans too
if you think i'm excited about [__]
going in there tomorrow and
going through this [__] again you're
[__] wrong
you know i talked to patrick from the
stand we were talking he was telling me
about a situation where
he had a friend that did the surgery
they had to go back a year later
because your knee gets infected i don't
know i i've tried to avoid everything i
can
i've tried to work out i've tried to eat
clean i'm drinking water like a
[__]
i'm taking my [__] supplements i'm
cutting down on the weed 50
as hard as that seems you could tell
look at my balls
they're [__] clean guys i'm i'm i'm
trying my [__] artist here
because i knew that if i kept with the
edibles and the [__] band-aids
i wasn't gonna make any progress and
that wasn't gonna help you guys
and that's not going to help me god i
want you to listen to my words on what
i'm telling you right now
clear your head if you feel that
your mind is controlling you or taking
you into a different place
do a restart get to that notebook get
that notebook out
get a restart talk to somebody call
people that you love
call people that you trust do a zoom
i can't tell you listen i [__] hate
zoom
more than i hate hummus do you
understand me i hate zoom
all right all right i'm lying yeah i'm
sorry mike
yeah i'm sorry
[__] it [__]
i hate zoom but i tell you what i fall
in love with zoom
because i get to see my friends again
yes so it has been
it had that has brought a [__] smile
to my face
you know so all these things have
changed us but in a way for the better
like we've all changed
we've had to make adjustments some of us
have made them you know
if you thought i wanted to end the
church
i never wanted to end the church but i
had no choice it was time to move
forward there was so many little things
that it was time to regroup and move the
[__] forward we've all had to go through
things so
listen man right you know i say it at
the end of my draftkings read and
i [__] mean it if you have a gaming
problem
call 1-800 get help it sounds like a
joke
and i make it a joke just to alleviate
it but i'm not
if you guys in your heart feel
that you need to talk to somebody pick
up that call
there's no stigma attached
dog i've had to call a thousand people
to get to the root of my [__] problem
i didn't know what it was
but i knew by rapping i could [__]
figure this out i had to get to the root
of this
i wanted to know why i was feeling the
way i was
what was making me take anxiety pills
what was making me
[__] eat a thousand milligrams of thc
by [__] lunchtime what was making me
do all these things
what was making me take [__] you know
a thousand those pills to fall asleep
and i had to knock myself out
i'm not like most people i want to know
the answers
i look so i look within you have to look
within you have to blame yourself look
with it and go what the [__] am i doing
to myself
why is this happening you know i've been
getting emails from people joey allman
a couple of guys i'm quitting smoking
pot i do not blame you
i do not blame you i want you to get in
touch with yourself
i want you to get in touch with your
true feelings i'm getting emails from
people that they quitting booze
i'm not blaming you give it a chance
get to know the real you just for one
week get to know the real you
for me listen i smoke in the morning for
appetite
but for obstruction purposes i'm not
smoking i'm working out i'm going on
walks
i'm working on the guitar i talk on the
phone with erica we're putting the book
together
thank god the [__] uh proposal is
ready
these are all little achievements that
are little achievements
but they're big to me and they make me
go one more day
do things that i'm gonna make you go one
more day
what could make me go one more day if
it's talking to this person on the phone
i don't care if you pull up to their
house and talk to them social distance
10 feet away
the weather is warming up now you can do
that but
there's no reason that you should be
feeling what you should be feeling
i am not the type of guy that would ever
tell you
to go see a therapist but after this
year
from what i've seen and what i've heard
in people's voices and what i've read on
the internet
and the messages i'm getting from you
i'll tell you i see these things online
these uh zoom
psychiatrists that you could talk to
guys that's an option
if you think i'm gonna sit here and call
you a [__] momo because you talk to
somebody to get help
i might goof on you a little bit but i'm
not meaning that from my heart
i want you to feel the best that you
could feel you have to feel the best
that you can feel right now
i'm doing everything i can and my power
to
loosen up the i mean my house is great
knock on wood
listen i love my wife more than i've
ever loved thank god
because some people aren't that lucky i
looked at her and i knew that
we could either go to [__] blows or
we could work together
and and and make this house the best
that it can be
i'm not talking about my big screen tvs
i'm not talking about my furniture or
swimming pools or a butler
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about the inside
this is what i said in the beginning of
this thing this is going to give you
everybody a chance to take you
you have to act proper on the outside
but most importantly the same way you
act inside your home
inside your home has to be [__] tip
top magoo
or everything else is background [__]
music i always work
i grew up in a house that was [__]
so i know what it is to feel shitty
because your house is shitty
your mom's shitty your dad and your mom
don't talk
you know all that i went through all
that we've never gotten into those
conversations yet because
we never had to but in the book i've
been writing and i've been thinking
about it
that's why i knew what family i wanted
you know
my mother dying gave me a chance to live
with different families
and see different families and different
family dynamics
i knew what i wanted my family to be
happy i didn't want a house that
there was anger i don't want my daughter
growing up around that at all
i didn't want to do a house where my
daughter grows up
and sees the mother and father fighting
all the time over stupid [__]
i don't want that type of house that's
not what i want i want a loving home
and i want to feel that and extend that
to you guys so please if you're feeling
something that you
feel awkward you know i mean listen
those uh
therapy things like 35 bucks i've seen
them really [__] cheap you know
online
i think it's time for some people to
actually talk to people
it's secure too it's through telehealth
not zoom it's like a totally different
thing
guys i'm telling you you know uh
people are going through things there's
no stigma
i read these emails i i'm not a
therapist
i try to give you love and push you in
the right direction but
it's time to take care of ourselves it
really is i'm not talking about
jumping jacks and whatever i'm talking
about your mind
because mental health is on an all-time
[__] rise so if it's listening to me
if it's me emailing back and forth with
you
if there's anything i could do to help
you know i'm here to talk
you know i answer emails on facebook
i answer twitter emails if you think you
want a little bit more personalized and
you want to join patreon
we'll cover it there but uh i just want
you to really take care of yourselves
this time of the year
right now don't think the party's over
don't think that this is it
we're done it's spring let's go out and
[__] jump up and down no no
no no no no not don't get too [__]
excited yet
we're not out of the [__] weeds yet
let's let this summer pass by let's keep
our eye on the [__] prize
let's see what goes on this summer and
then you can start doing whatever you
want
you know me i'm coming i'm going to be
every monday and wednesday
now i got no choice now with my leg down
i'm going to [__]
be down so i'm going to work harder on
this i'm going to try to get some great
guests for you guys
i've been reaching out to people you
know i like to
zoom [__] experience for you guys i
like the balance
we're giving you a hybrid podcast right
now this is what it is
you got a guest you got me one day if
you don't like me
jerry go [__] yourself we're only gonna
listen on monday that's fine too
you know me my feelings have been hurt
you can't that sticks and stones will
break my bones
words will never help hurt me at this
point in the [__] game
so whatever you want to do is fine with
me i'm throwing you a hybrid podcast
and we're going to keep growing right
before your eyes while the scottish
podcast
is up to episode three on patreon
it is what it is my spanish is good this
week we spoke about bulgarians
which is those guys that uh that mess
with gay guys
they let gay guys suck their dick and
they [__] gay guys in the ass but they
don't suck dick and they don't get
[__] in the ass
it's just a certain thing that happened
yeah it's a cuban thing that goes back
to the prisons
i don't get involved and i know nothing
about it i just talked about it on the
[__] another scottie guy because we
were listening to music
and i was telling stories about san
francisco in 85 and whatnot
but i'm here for you guys and uh
i know what i went through and it wasn't
fun and i was open about it with you
guys as much as i could
i hope you guys are as open with
somebody take one thing from me
listen i'm just a loser [__] dirty
comic i'm not a celebrity
i'm not a movie star i'm not anything
but i will tell you one thing
i use my friends for what
they're there for to talk you have
friends
you have family don't be shy don't
worry talk to them let them know what
you're feeling
let them know what you're going through
we're here for you man we're here for
one another
especially these tough times and you as
a human being like i told you
it's not about money it's not about fame
it's not about being cool
it's about making somebody's [__] day
taking two minutes away from somebody
maybe a smile you know what a smile
could do for somebody
just a simple [__] smile just like
how the [__] are you doing
just a smile to help somebody that's
that's the hand we're playing right now
we're taking care of ourselves and we're
making somebody's day beyond that i
don't know what else to tell you
thank you for watching today thank you
for following us i hope you enjoyed the
greg fitzsimmons one
i did i laughed my balls off uh
the [__] story about my daughter with
the
[__] archie bunker with the [__] is
true i'm sorry if i offended anybody
i didn't mean to offend anybody that was
the humor back in the 70s
and that's just the way it goes but
listen guys i love you guys
uh i do not have covert if you're
uh if you hear that rumor i do not have
covert
and i'm just getting this thing done to
my leg tomorrow morning and uh we're
gonna move forward
thank you very much for listening thank
you for watching
thank you for being here thank you for
supporting and now
for a word from our [__]
sponsor by the way
boulder god bless you thank you
there was a reason why i never went back
to bold and that's because
i acted like a [__] and i always
felt guilty last time i was in boulder
was in 98
when uh my wife didn't show up with my
daughter and just
i got to walk around boulder and uh
see what i had done and even all my
trips to denver
i never went back to boulder because i
was ashamed of what i did
so i just want to tell the residents of
boulder
the universal bold and the mountains are
bolder i'm very sorry for my behavior
and that someday when i feel that
i've gone through my uh
my probationary period of not being
allowed back in boulder
i will go back and say i'm sorry to the
mountains personally
i love you boulder colorado i'm very
sorry you went through this
for everybody else have a great weekend
and i'll see you
monday the 29th [__] uh easter week
whatever the [__] it is next week so
it's a good week for catholics
i love you [__] and now for a
word from our sponsors
all right you [__] thank you very
much for listening
this wednesday i know this was a a weird
podcast today
it is what it is you got to cover all
the [__] bases but
it's what it's all about before we get
out of here a word
from our sponsors first of all i want to
thank
honda.com has been with me since day one
since we were [__]
in my [__] bedroom before mercy came
so
listen as far as i'm concerned on this
[__] gold
they're a great company to work with and
their products are tremendous
i still use them on a daily basis and
i've been using them in my recovery
alpha brain tremendous shroom tech
tremendous you don't like pills
they got them in a powder form their
protein bites were on sale
i think they're still on sale additional
those uh peanut butter ones are
tremendous the coconut
cashews are tremendous honor is just a
great company to do business with go to
honor.com right now
go through their website i can't help
you with the club bats and whatnot
but as far as supplements i got you 10
try that [__] melatonin the beef
jerky is tremendous i mean come on guys
go to honor.com right now take a look at
what they got you like something that
you uh
think it might help you bam order it and
get 10
off by pressing church i'm going to give
you 10 off by getting the party started
church
and you get 10 percent off delivered
right to your house the joint is also
brought to you by
expressvpn listen every time you go
online
it's just [__] somebody's watching
you have to [__] assume
in this life somebody's watching it's
like going to vegas you go to vegas you
got to jerk off in the closet because
you know
somebody's [__] watching when i did
coke i would have to hide the [__]
closet
because i knew somebody's watching so
it's the same thing with the computer
you don't want people looking
on you so why would you let you you see
what you're doing online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom and not
closing the [__] door
do you know that creepy internet
providers actually spy on what you do
you did you do know that right
you have to [__] assume that every
single website you visit
turns around and sells your info to ad
companies no more
you want a privacy you have a little red
dot that looks at you over the computer
you want privacy
you don't want nobody to know what
you're clicking into maybe you're
thinking of becoming a transvestite
maybe you're thinking of [__] taking
steroids whatever the [__] you're
thinking of i don't i don't give a [__]
i use expressvpn because it puts a stop
to this madness
it creates a secure tunnel between you
and the internet no one can see what
you're up to
it's between you and the big man
upstairs that's it
and it works on all devices and on wi-fi
it covers everyone in your home plus
it's easy to use as closing the [__]
door
you push one button and you're protected
it's that [__] easy
that's why expressvpn is rated number
one
listen if you want to jerk off the
japanese [__] porn
this is the way to do it so if you're
like me and you believe your online
activity is your [__] business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
joey that's expressvpn.com
joy what i'm gonna do for you
[__] is this i'm gonna give you
three months for free
three months for free that's it
expressvpn.com
joey support the joint and protect your
privacy
with expressvpn.com joey last and not
least
from the [__] heart of new jersey my
peeps over at draftkings
making your life easier and putting a
little guidance in your [__] pocket
it's almost april and you're [__]
still sitting there it's as hard as can
be right now and [__] if you want to
gamble a little bit
get off the [__] bench get your dick
back in your pocket
get you put your dick back in your pants
i'm sorry and bet a dollar on any
tournament game
if your team wins you win a hundred
dollars it's that [__] simple
pick any college basketball team that's
still in the running for your shot at
winning a hundred
[__] dollars it all all it takes is a
[__] dollar
that's a 100 to one odds what the [__]
are you waiting for
put your [__] college basketball
knowledge to a test you've been watching
they all [__] went
along and now comes the time to make
money and you're [__] sitting there
with your hands and your pants and
and [__] lent in your pocket college
basketball ain't for you well let me
tell you something
ufc 260 has a tremendous card this
weekend
you got tyrone woodley fighting you got
[__] sean o'malley throwing fists
but you got steeped up against my man um
who's pissed it
as [__] right now download the top rated
sportsbook app today
and use promo code joey draftkings is
safe
secure and [__] reliable
withdraw your money when you want it's
your [__] getus
so that's called joey to turn one dollar
into 100
enough is enough for a limited time only
at draftkings sportsbook app
and here's the fine print you got to be
21 or [__] older all right
listen i don't know what to tell you go
to the pizza parlor go torture the pizza
guy or something
new customers only new jersey indiana pa
only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbooks for details now if you got a
gambling problem listen you gotta take
care of it
i had problems i took care of them and
here we are you gotta take care of it
call one eight hundred gambler
or call 1-809 with it but if not
i'll tell you what go download the
draftking sportsbook app
make a hundred dollars and keep [__]
running you got ufc saturday night
you got more ncaa action you got nba
action make some money get your dick
sucked live like a doctor
that could be you on that [__] yacht
with four little butlers you understand
me
but it starts by downloading the
draftking sports book act
and using promo code joey have a great
weekend i love you [__]
i want to thank all my sponsors from the
bottom of my heart cbd lion
on it expressvpn manscape you guys
[__] rocked
have a great week uncle joey loves you
stay black
how you like me now
[Music]
so
foreign
you